correspondent martha keller joins us now
um
martha what can be done that's that's
the big question and and the really key
thing is this should have been a moment
to savor
for a young england side which on the
picture going from strength to strength
this is their
first major qualifying competition since
of course they reached the semi-finals
of the world cup in russia last summer
um and and they're a young team who are
you know making their way and it's it's
the second time second consecutive match
they've scored five goals they of course
beat the czech republic
five nil at wembley on friday night and
we we should be swept away
with a wave of excitement about this
team but instead last night's game was
was completely overshadowed
by racism you had what appeared to be
vast swathes of the crowd in montenegro
making monkey noises towards the black
players on the england team
um first towards danny rose and the
young chelsea player callum hudson
adoye um and it was it was sad to see
and it's it's also
caused a lot of consternation because we
seem to be seeing these scenes
repeatedly particularly in certain
countries
and if they have made a complaint to uae
for um about this racism